i read that you were working on a
live-action
dungeons and dragon series is that still
the case
yeah yeah uh with chris johnson over e1
um
kind of building out a universe based
on a certain segment of uh that d
population
and it's a joy but man it gets deep and
and uh
it gets deep right quick i mean i love
you know i grew up with all that kind of
stuff dude one of the rings uh
you know uh uh language of the wardrobe
i mean
you you name the fan dragon lancer my
favorite you know i met him when i was
in junior high
um but the dnd thing's a joy but it's
also a little bit of a
uh not an experiment not not an
experiment but kind of like
okay like i was saying about world war
ii movies i don't want to do
uh you know a massive uh longest day
i want to do you know um a tinier
uh sliver of that world and it's been a
it's
been a joy and in fact i'm delivering it
to him today
oh like a script or an outline it's a
bible i mean i i
we talked last november and he's like
what would you do and i was like here's
here's how i'd do it and it was a 12
page treatment of here's here's episode
one this is my way into the world
and he came back with ho-ho-ho-ho yes
and then we started building that out
and it's the bible and format that take
forever um but it's it's
i can't wait for you guys to see it yeah
listen my opinion
is that a dungeons and dragons
live-action
series if done right could be
massive just massive especially based on
what we've seen with game of thrones and
the
how much in the last decade superheroes
and fantasy and everything has
permea for me uh has gotten into popular
culture
um so i am curious with something like
that
because of how many creatures could be
in it dragons
bfx world building how much
i mean this thing could be very
expensive it can't it can be
and then and i i i kind of go defer back
to my childhood
in respect to in the first star wars
you've heard about jabba the hutt
and you don't see him to the third one
because you earn at that point whatever
the budget was for the third one
compared the
first one who cares right and i think in
dungeons and dragons who has this
massive dedicated
uh community of acolytes it's like i
don't want to
suddenly throw everything on screen and
and say here's the buffet
you'd much rather keep the story
intimate you know when you think of our
favorite movies
uh you know it's it's it's when you
think of first i'd rather do the first
blood version
you know it's uh you know that it's a
guy in the woods being hunted
and it's very small but you allude to
the other things through conversation
you have your uss indianapolis you see
something in the background
you hear a name that three percent of
the audience is like oh i think we're
gonna see him soon
you know uh i think the thing is just to
take a deep breath
to go into it slowly and to just respect
the world and as you adapt
certain things need to change but you
better not touch the heart and soul of
why
people love this thing you know do you
obviously
they're making a dungeons in dragon's
movie at the same time
do you get to use a title like d
or do you you have to avoid the title
and do something completely different
i i don't know you know right it's not
quite that
the document is you know work in
progress i just call it d
um but you know i think the rights are
kind of splendor between film and tv
um the hasbro e1 paramount agreements of
it all
and yet i'm like you want everything to
succeed because that's only good for the
franchise as a whole
you know and we've all waited you know
i'm 46 so most of my life for
for a dungeons and dragons thing outside
i'm a huge
the pc games man they've they forged and
formed me in the 80s 90s and odds and
beyond i played all of those that's how
i know the world um but the movies have
been questionable at best in the past
you know so looking at that you want to
do
what it is does and if it's this massive
spectacle at a quarter billion dollars
that does well
great because i want my show to exist in
a little little subset shadow of it
and go deeper and deeper into the
underdark you know completely and the
other thing is
with the series which and man listen i
watch a lot of movies just like you
and um i have recently
realized that i i've really enjoyed
series so much because it allows
people to you know you have more time
with the characters and you have more
smaller moments where you can have
dialogue scenes where
you don't have to have an action set
piece you know every 15 minutes or
you know anyway yeah no i could but i
agree but you think your favorite scenes
in a movie
like indiana jones is a great example in
the first raiders right
it's him the swordsman it's him running
away it's him failing it's all these
little character beats
that even the action sequences
everything is a character beat
in tv you get to pause and let's be
honest our favorite episodes of our
favorite series tend to be the one where
they ran out of money
and it's two guys in a room it's the
bottle episode and they talk they go
deep and they say
you know i am the man who knocks or
whatever the classic line is that i
can't remember right now
from breaking bad those are your
favorite moments action's action
you know and we'll get to that it'll be
cool but when a guy says or does a
certain thing
uh that's where tv has a strong point
you know
oh completely um are you guys
envisioning one of the other things i
really like
is you know eight and ten episode
seasons because you can have a you know
contained story et cetera et cetera are
you already envisioning have you guys
had that conversation where you're
envisioning it at
eight episodes or ten episodes you know
the marvel beast of it all in regards to
not the marvel i'd say the whole disney
beast of it all with the mandalorian
and with one division with falconer
soldier of
uh you can have a half hour live action
that sometimes you have
them go to 50 minutes or an hour you
know i don't know i think the last
mandalorian was almost 50 minutes right
um i love that idea of six to eight
episodes i mean it's been kind of the
bbc model for the last 30 years
and yet i also like the breathing room
that doesn't have to be a certain number
of pages a certain number of
uh format length and let's say you
announced six episodes
and surprised we had enough footage for
seven everyone's happy right
so i love the six to eight to ten right
and
i think that out the gate you got to
figure out what that's going to be
and yet within it you have the
flexibility of time to make it fit
you know um i'm not a i mean i'm not a
22 episode guy
unless we're doing 10 minute web series
um
i i got nothing against procedural but i
like the serialized notion of
this isn't just a long movie cut into
pieces
it is a serialized show much like the
old radio
and i that's where my excitement lies
you know sure with the bible that you
wrote
is it one of these things where in it
sort of like lays out a vision for five
years or seven years or like the
overarching
story or is it one of these things where
you're just building the world and
explaining the creatures and
the races it can i mean but if you're
good
if you were to do that um it's a it's
more than a hundred page document and no
one's gonna read that
i'm not gonna reread it if i wrote it um
i think what i'm trying to do is go look
uh to everyone out there you know what
this is uh here's the world
here's the characters and we're just
gonna kind of give you an idea
and then here's the first episode and i
think the first episode of any series
is the second most important because
it's the second episode that gets
talons in you everyone will watch the
pilot but are you gonna stick with it
um and then once i have those it's like
here's the first season
and then any other time you can go
second season and really build it out
but i can't i i stick with macro at this
stage in the game because
this thing is such an important ip you
have to be malleable
and so i will i'll i'll stick to my guns
when it comes to the characters
and certain aspects of the world but as
to the story
a lot of times by the time you start
shooting you throw away the bible going
hey it got us here but now look where we
are and you have to rebuild
so honestly i like that document between
uh
this one right now it's about 40 pages
um but it's the one that's
internal the one that you're actually
going to send out it will hopefully be
rendered down to the sweetest of the
meats you know
sure did you there's so much d d out
there
mentioned dragon lands there's so many
expansion modules and
adventures that have been done do you
guys have the rights to
anything that has been written or is it
all
you just creating you know what you want
to do no no no i
i honestly when it comes to the rights
of things we're at the nascent stages
stages of this and once the document is
locked let's send it to legal and go you
can use this you can't use that get that
i'm sure you know the same thing
happened with
uh falcon winter soldier characters that
you know you could use or you couldn't
use right
um and i think with this it's going to
be a matter of
look everything exists in the background
uh you know
this is you know where we are is not
after the fact but like
i don't want to go in the middle of the
mythos i want to come near the end we're
almost
where everything is uh canonical it's
biblical like it's happened
or uh it's about to happen you know
that way you can you can revisit certain
uh sequences and storylines that
everyone loved
uh in the past through flashback but
where we go is new uh
the unique yet familiar of it all is why
we return to the games we love you know